what is vision mean vision means being
able to see beauty especially in human
faces and that I grieve the loss of that
my macular degeneration started about
eight years ago it results in loss of
central focus vision like I'm looking
directly the camera right now actually
can't see the lens of that camera at all
I can't recognize faces I can't read
hard copy any longer
I'm so blessed that I won't be totally
blind from this disease but it does
definitely impact your life in terms of
your functionality rosemary is one of
about eight million Americans who are
partially or completely blind the damage
to her retina is irreversible so there's
no biological cure for her fading vision
in recent years Bionic technology has
allowed us to make headway against some
disabilities by integrating humans with
machines but creating Bionic vision has
remained a sticky problem
no one has quite been able to untangle
the complex relationship between the eye
and the brain at least not yet about
three years ago I was working on a
problem and I suddenly realized that
with the information that I had I could
actually make a device to potentially
restore sight to the blind and once I
thought of that I've just been sort of a
maniac
working on it steadily ever since
[Music]
people have been working on prosthetic
Stu to help blind people probably for
more than 20 years and the focus has
mostly been on implanting electrodes
into a patient's retina so the patient
will see a spot of light wherever the
electrode is when people first put these
implants into patients it was it was
really exciting you know to be able to
drive a blind retina so that the patient
even saw anything but it wasn't that
effective and nobody worried about it
that much at the time because they
assumed well we just had more electrodes
we'll just make it better and better and
everything everything will be okay but
but it isn't really true that there was
other another factor that was missing
and that's the signal processing
basically the code that the retina uses
to communicate with the brain so when
information comes into your eye it goes
into your photoreceptors and then it
goes through all this complicated
circuitry to the retinas output cells
and then they send the signals to the
brain the big question is what code do
they use to give us a sensation of
seeing something so this is what I work
on anyway I was working on it as a basic
scientist so you can take a retina out
of an animal's eye and you can put it on
a bed of electrodes
and you can present it with all sorts of
images and record the the output and so
you can figure out what the relationship
between the outside world is and the
code that the the brain wants to receive
so we were doing this
and we unraveled it this is vision the
code the eye uses to communicate with
the brain if you're looking at this
image of a baby's face your brain is
receiving this pattern of electrical
signals we've known for decades that
this code exists but dr. Nuremberg is
the first to have cracked and I realized
that not only was it useful for figuring
out you know as a stepping stone toward
figuring out how the brain works but it
had a huge potential application that we
could use this to make a prosthetic
device for restoring sight to the blind
okay so here is like a sort of simple
lab prototype of our device so it has a
camera here and it's taking images in
goes into an encoder device which sends
the signals out to this piece of paper
and the signals are are in the neural
code so let's say I put my hand here if
the brain were to get this pattern it
would know that it was in somebody's
hand was moving like that so the way it
would be implemented in the real world
for a patient has two parts so one part
is it is a device that could be worn
like as glasses that will take the
images in it sends the code in the form
of light pulses to interact with
something that we've injected into the
eye it's a gene called channelrhodopsin
when you shine a spotlight on it it
causes the cell to fire an electrical
pulse so you can picture that you could
just pulse it in the pattern of the
neural code and it would send the images
up to the brain
[Music]
you look great as always nice to see you
so you spend 99% of all your time right
yeah so I want to show you what the
goggles look like because that's the
part that you know everything else is
internal and this part is the external
part by the time we start you know if we
do the clinical trial start and let's
say eight months or and then it goes
through for a year we can fit everything
into you know fashionable glasses
stylish would be important right yes
once you can see yourself as we say you
w care how you look right right so do
you see can you see this at all not
really okay it's little flickering green
lights okay I can see flickers now what
yes yes doctor Nuremberg next step is to
hold human trials to prove her
technology can actually restore vision
patients like rosemary would be injected
with the light-sensitive gene and then
be shown images in the neural code the
best-case scenario is to have somebody
be able to see faces to create that
contact of interacting with other people
but even if it doesn't work the first
time just knowing that I have the code
and then I pass it on to the next
generation then someone else will be
able to do it I don't even dare go down
that path of hoping that there will be a
cure for this disease but it would be a
miracle if I could see again clearly as
I used to be able to see
[Music]